hi I'm max fans I'm Jennifer Lawrence
I'm excited for you to experience the
hunger games catching fire in the most
amazing way possible by seeing it at
your local IMAX theater want you guys to
forget everything you think you know
about the games last year was child's
play this year you're dealing with all
experienced killers I think it's gonna
be really interesting because I've
always been a huge fan of IMAX the IMAX
camera is the world's highest resolution
image capture device that film frame is
equivalent to 18,000 lines of resolution
its unsurpassed in the world of digital
what the filmmaker Francis Lawrence did
is he embraced the IMAX camera for the
most exciting moments in the film we
decided to use the imax thematically for
the arena we decided you know what we're
gonna stay scope all the way up until
the moment she goes into the arena and
then as she's going up that elevator
that screen will open up that is such an
incredible moment to choose to go into
I'm actin she's coming up out of this
because she's kind of seeing this new
world
remember who the real enemy is